bonjour et merci de nous avoir rejoint
dans filco l'émission qui revient sur
l'actualité économique locale nous
recevons aujourd'hui àint tailleur de
l'Union départementale CGT et Bertrand
Decré président du MDEF Eveline nous
parlerons dans bonsoir à tous les deux
nous parlerons dans un instant du pacte
de responsabilité lancé dernièrement par
le président mais avant ça on passe à
l'actualité économique de la
semaine McDonald dont le siège social
est à gui en cours soupçonné de fraude
fiscale selon le ministère des Finances
l'entreprise aurait trans transféré
pardon 2,2 milliards d'euros à
l'étranger au Luxembourg et en Suisse
sans s'acquiter du paiement de la TVA et
de l'impôt sur les bénéfices le manque à
gagné pour le fisque est estimé entre
330 et 650 millions d'euros la direction
reconnaît que son siège a été
perquésitionné en octobre mais ni toute
fraude comment McDonald's il serait pris
et bien par le biaet de ses franchises
elle représente tout de même 80 % de ses
magasins en France et doivent bien sûr
laisser un pourcentage de leur chiffre
d'affaires à McDonald's le problème
c'est que les versements se feraient
auprès de deux surcursales en Suisse et
au Luxembourg justement à Versailles
maintenant les entreprises recrutent
plus de 400 offres d'emploi sont à pour
voir un forum permettra de rencontrer
les recruteurs le 12 février et en
attendant des ateliers permettent de s'y
préparer tous les mardis soirs images
d'éodim moine Aicha recherche un emploi
et souhaite être épaulé dans sa
recherche mardi soir à la maison de
quartier prè au bois à Versailles elle a
découvert cet atelier de préparation aux
entretiens d'embauche un atelier qui
tombe à pique et qui s'inscrit dans le
cadre de l'opération un mois pour
l'emploi j'ai déjà un CV mais bon je
vrais voir voir par rapport aux
personnes qui sont ici est-ce que le CV
est bien fait ou pas et en plus on peut
envoyer directement je pense à à
l'entreprise donc c'est intéressant pour
moi ça parce que je cherche du travail
étant étant mère de qure enfants les
entreprises partenaires de l'événement
cherche à recruter ce recueil regroupe
l'ensemble de leurs offres de postees de
l'aide soignante au chef de projet
informatique les candidats se préparent
aujourd'hui à rencontrer leur recruteurs
lors d'un Forum de l'Emploi le 12
février prochain en fait préparation de
CV simulation d'entretien en même temps
puis que quand on travaille sur un CV on
peut travailler aussi l'entretien
d'uneune certaine façon après c'est
quand même très limité parce que
travailler un CV une lettre de
candidature et puis un entretien ça
prend
normalement beaucoup de temps voilà donc
on essaie de surtout de faire le lien
entre ce qui sera proposé le jour du
forum et ce que les personnes recherche
en tant que cible professionnelle ce
mois pour l'emploi s'adresse en priorité
aux jeunes mais le public présent
dépasse largement cette catégorie d'âge
ce type d'atelier sera reconduit tous
les mardis soirs jusqu'au 12
février près de 60 % des internautes
compent profiter des soldes sur internet
un chiffre en haut selon la dernière
étude de la Fevad la Fédération du
e-commerce et de la vente à distance
nous sommes allés dresser un premier
bilan des ventes avec Christan goazou
président fondateur d'igral sa société
propose du cashback c'est-à-dire un
pourcentage du prix payé qui revient à
l'acheteur il travaille avec 1400
commerçants en ligne avec les soldes
divivers il nous a confi avoir dépassé
tous les records en terme de vente en
janvier on est au-delà de nos espérances
donc il se passe quelque chose alors
peut-être que c'est dû à la notoriété
d'igral qui est croissante mais sans
doute que encore plus c'est les
consommateurs ont ancré dans leurs
habitudes
d'achat d'attendre d'attendre les soldes
pour acheter beaucoup et en particulier
sur internet concernant les chiffres de
janvier
euh on est est en gros à quasiment 50 %
de plus que l'année dernière donc c'est
vraiment très impressionnant pour nous
en tout cas donc c'est bien au-delà de
la croissance du e-commerce qui je crois
que en 2013 était de de l'ordre de 10-
15 % ben les gens sont sensibles
probablement en période de crise aussi
encore plus au aux réductions qu'on
propose et les achats en solde sur
smartphone continuent également de se
développer avec près de 41 %
d'utilisateurs en région
parisienne le site de ske France à
Montini a été bloqué lundi matin par des
salariés selon les sources de 40 à 60
grevistes en cause le PSE le plan de
sauvtage de l'entreprise lancé en
octobre par la direction autrement dit
un plan social dans le cadre d'une
restructuration 51 salariés du site de
Montini seront déplacés sur le site
principal de SKF en France à saint-sir
surloire près de tour pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas la société il s'agit du
leader mondial dans le domaine du
roulement mécanique son siège social est
en Suède il emploie 3500 personnes en
France dont 350 sur le site de Montini
nous avions rencontré lundi greviste
mais aussi la direction le mouvement
regroupe aujourd'hui l'ensemble des
syndicats du site ils ont trouvé un
accord le point avec une syndicaliste le
PSE effectivement il y a la partie la
clause de mobilité pour les personnes
pouvant se déplacer à saincir ou pour là
effectivement il y a il y a des choses
qui sont faites même si c'est en D de ce
que peut faire SKF il y a il y a des
choses qui sont faites et la deuxième
partie c'est pour les gens qui ne
partiront pas puisqueeffectivement la
majorité ne partiront pas et là SKF
n'avait rien prévu donc on se bat encore
sur ce point les proposition de la CGT
de la CFDT ont été les les suivantes
c'est donc la pérénisation des des
emplois pour les personnes de Montini
allant à saincir pour 18 mois donc là on
vient d'apprendre que la direction avait
accordé euh la deuxème demande c'est
donc une prime au-delà en plus des des
des primes licenciement légal de 30000 €
on attend encore une réponse euh voilà
les deux principales deux principales
demandes donc le mouvement continue on
ne s'essouffle pas et on s'essoufflera
pas une entreprise récompensée pour ses
efforts environnementaux les pépinières
tuyau basés à Choisel ont reçu le Prix
entreprise environnement 2013 un prix
décerné entre autres par le Conseil
Général cette société créant 1650
produit des arbres et des conifère
garantie sans pesticide ce prix est un
moyen de se faire connaître et
d'acquérir une renommée car la
concurrence est rude comme nous
l'explique le directeur de ces
pépinières au micro d'Olivier
Maniscalco il va falloir que ça
s'arrange ou malheureusement il y y a
des entreprises qui vont disparaître ou
des licenciements qui vont qui vont
s'opérer comme malheureusement dans
d'autres domaines ça arrive ça peut pas
rester on peut pas refaire sans qu'il y
ait de conséquences grave ce qui s'est
passé en 2013 ça c'est vrai que ça
pourra pas on pourra pas refaire encore
une année dans les mêmes conditions on
est même en train de de restraindre nos
misisees en culture notre production on
va moins planter cette année parce qu'on
n pas on n pas les moyens de le faire
c'est trop c'est trop trop compliqué
donc voyez on est déjà en train de de
serrer tous les budgets de diminuer un
petit peu la la voilure pour les pour
pour la l'avenir proche en tout cas de
la mise en culture donc c'est c'est déjà
euh grave pour nous qui sommes
producteurs on ne fait pas d'achat et de
revente hein c'est un métier nous notre
métier on on produit et on vend on va
pas si vous me demandez un un un un
chaîn vert qui pas du tout de de la
région ben je vais pas vous vendre de
chaîn ver parce que ça vient du sud
d'Italie et cetera voilà par rapport à
ça donc on est vraiment tributaire de ce
qu'on produit et ce qu'on met en culture
et donc quand on commence à être obligé
de réduire notre mise en production
parce qu'on a des problèmes économiques
c'est forcément inquiétant pour pour
l'avenir
un plateau technique de formation au
métier de la fibre doit bientôt être
créé à Aubergenville il servira à former
dans les conditions dur réel des
techniciens pour installer la fibre
optique il n'existe pour le moment qu'un
centre de formation de ce type en France
il intégrera l'itdec l'institut de
formation au tertières au développement
durable et à l'éconstruction le Conseil
Général financera presque entièrement
cette structure 1,3 million d'euros la
Chambre de commerce de son côté
s'occupera de l'entretien pendant 10 ans
la verrière tressetel et la MGEN ont
remporté de leur côté un appel à projet
lancé par l'État le projet vise à
développer les pôles territoriaux de
coopération économique le but permettre
le maintien à domicile des personnes
âgées un central une centrale
d'opération pardon permettra de les
assister grâce à des capteurs installés
à leur domicile et c'est la fin de cette
page d'actualité on passe à
l'entretien
le sujet de cet entretien le pacte de
responsabilité alors pour débattre
là-dessus nous recevons à l'intérieur de
l'Union départementale de la CGT bonsoir
et Bertrand Decré président du M
fiveline bonsoir à vous aussi alors le
pacte de responsabilité donc pour rappel
il s'agit donc d'une annonce du du
président lors de ces vux une baisse des
charges pour les entreprises contre des
embauches alors il est revenu un peu
plus en détail lors de la cérémonie au
vœux aux acteurs économique mardi
dernier alors trois points essentiels la
suppression des cotisations familiales
pour les employeurs donc ça veut dire
une baisse de 30 milliards d'euros la
simplification des démarches
administratives et enfin la refonte de
la fiscalité pour s'aligner sur les pays
européens d'ici 2020 reste à définir du
coup les contreparties c'est aussi un
gros point Bertrand decret tout d'abord
le président du MDEF pierre gataz a
indiqué que ce pacte était inspiré du
pacte de confiance proposé au
gouvernement fin 2013 ça veut donc dire
que vous êtes plutôt satisfait content
de cette mesure oui euh clairement le le
Pr président de la République a repris
quasiment intégralement la lettre que
lui avait fait pierre gataz au mois de
novembre alors après là de la sémantique
PCT de confiance P de responsabilité on
choisira les les les grands axes sont là
c'est qu'aujourd'hui le constat et que
nos entreprises sont sont écrasé de
charge qu'aujourd'hui la croissance est
à tonne et qu'il faut la développer donc
le moteur c'est c'est nous leons une
baisse despenses publiqu un allègement
des charges pour s'aligner sur la
fiscalité européenne tout à fait et donc
aujourd'hui bien les paroles ont été
données nous attendons les actes par
contre alors du côté des des syndicats
la nouvelle a été plutôt prise de
manière différente on va dire concernant
voilà concernant la CGT quelle réaction
première alors déjà pour la CGT je pense
que c'est ce qui a été dit euh vous
comprendrez qu'on ne peut pas être
satisfait des annonces faites par le
président à partir du moment quand on
voit la satisfaction du
MF sur ces annonces les syndicats ne
peuvent pas être et la CGT en
particulier ne peut pas être d'accord
parce que déjà deux points très rapides
euh des aides ça fait des années que des
aides ont été
accordées aux entreprises pour créer des
emplois force de constater que il y a
pas eu d'emploi puisque le chômage
continue d'augmenter d'année en année
orors que des aides il y en a déjà eu
donc de nouvelles aides qu'est-ce
qu'elle créerait comme emploi et on
demande
déjà on demande déjà du cice mais même
toutes les aides globalement on estime à
230 milliards les aides accordées aux
entreprises depuis des années parant
bien sûr et donc où sont les emplois qui
auraient dû être créés et donc on
demande déjà une remise à plat de tout
ça alors y compris j'entends au travers
de la fiscalité parce que c'est une des
revendications de la CGT de revoir toute
la fiscalité et quand j'entendais tout à
l'heure que vous parliez de la
suppression
de l'IDE familiale c'est quand même un
acquis de
1945 et jusqu'à présent c'est pas lui
qui a empêché le développement euh des
entreprises et qui on empêché le
développement de l'emploi dans les
années où euh ça fonctionnait à peu près
bien donc où est le où est le où est le
ressort cassé aujourd'hui et pour la CGT
je terminerai là-dessus dans un premier
temps pour la CGT c'est les salaires et
dans les salaires on entend y compris le
salaire socialisé ce que le MDF appelle
charge nous on appelle ça un salaire
socialisé et ce salaire c'est bien les
Sala
qu' produisent au travers de leur
activité tous les jours dans
l'entreprise alors pour pour avancer il
y a des les modalités qui seront
discutées donc du coup le le 27 janvier
le Premier ministre va recevoir les
différents partenaires sociaux donc vous
ce qui sera demandé c'est un premier
bilan on l'a bien compris vous vous
demandez également des objectifs
contraignants en matière d'emploi je
cite de salaire de réduction de la
précariité d'investissement et de
relocalisation le président souhaite
également avoir des données un peu plus
spécifiques là on est un petit peu dans
dans le flou on va dire pour les
contreparties c'est quoi exactement en
fait ces objectifs contraignants alor
les objectif contraignant c'est ça
aujourd'hui pour continuer sur ce que je
disais toutes les aides n'ont fait que
abaisser le coût du travail le et entre
autres la baisse des salaires en les
tendant vers le salaire minimum parce
que les aides étaient données pour des
premiers emplois pour des choses comme
ça pour les salaires jusqu'à un moment
jusqu'à 1,6 Smic donc des salaires quand
même bas quand on sait que le salaire
médien en France il tourne autour de ce
que vous demandez c'est finalement en
fait un certain nombre d'emploi on a un
chiffre pour pour un certain minimum sal
c'est ça tout à fait et
puis moi j'ai pas de chiffr là
aujourd'hui à donner mais voilà on veut
que
derrière le medf s'engage sur des
chiffres d'emploi à créer
dans les entreprises dans les années qui
viennent parce que aujourd'hui c'est des
aides mais concrètement face on a on va
laisser aussi
la la
parole donc du coup vous de votre côté
d' je vais revenir sur il n'est pas
question de supprimer les aides aux
familles c'est un droit acquis
effectivement il s'agit que du
financement c'est le financement été
fait par les entreprises et ce sera
financé d'après ce qu'a dit le public là
j'y suis pour rien ce qu'il a dit sera
financé par de l'économie d'impôt mais
il n'a pas annoncé la su
au familles ça c'est pas c'est pas l'ORD
du jour
ENF
dép c'est le financement parce que
écoutez je veux bien qu'on parle de tout
et il faut parler de tout mais je suis
effectivement vous l'avez dit président
du MF mais je suis avant tout chef
d'entreprise j'ai une PME ivelinoise
alors moi dans depuis 2005 j'ai créé 45
emplois bon en tant que G j'ai créé 45
emplois j'ai eu des lois fillons qui
m'ont aidé qui m'ont permis d'embacher
et j'ai embauché j'ai eu des aides sur
l'apprentissage j'ai développé
énormément l'alternance chez moi et j'ai
embauché l'intégralité de mes apprentis
que j'ai formé donc là moi je vous parle
en tant que chef d'entreprise les aides
aujourd'hui je vous dis que je suis
écrasé de charge mais je vous le dis
clairement la masse salariale ce que je
cons salaire net brut charge tout
compris save tout ce que vous voulez
payer que je paye ce chiffre là me la
baisse j'embauche j'enuche alors vous
aviez indiqué d'ailleurs même sur notre
plateau pouvoir créer un million
d'emplois d'ici 5 ans si les charges
diminuer 200 100 milliards alors là on
parle de de 30 milliards de baisse de
charge on va on peut pas faire
d'équations Mad on ne peut pas faire
d'équations aussi simple maintenant il
est évident et moi je vous parle comme
un chef d'entreprise comme tous mes
adhérents qui sont tous des patrons de
PME on est sur le territoire moi les
adhérents que j'ai sont des entreprise
avec mes 45 salariés je suis une énorme
entreprise dans dans dans dans le
département f
Eveline alors je vois tous les chefs
d'entrepris que je que je rencontre ils
n'ont qu'une envie mais qu'une envie
c'est développer leur entreprise et pour
développer leur entreprise ça passe par
de l'embauche aujourd'hui il faut sortir
de cette idée reçu qu'un patron vit sur
une une entreprise statique dans
laquelle il y a des charges et puis s'il
y a moins de charges je j'ai gagé de
l'argent non on veut la développer on
passe par l'amont et si mon entreprise
est multipliée par 1 par 2 par 3 et ben
mes salariés sont par un par de par TR
et moi ce que je veux c'est avoir la
croissance VO pas on do on doit conclure
on a bien vu donc vous aviez des avis
très très opposé on en sera du coup un
peu plus le 27 janvier lors de cette
fameuse réunion et de toute façon ça
prendra un peu de temps puisqu'il y aura
la conclusion de ce Pact lors d'une
grande conférence économique et sociale
au printemps on vous donne rendez-vous
d'ici là merci à tous les deux d'être
venus on passe au dossier la
semaine
2014 année de la mixité professionnelle
pour le gouvernement mais qu'en est-il
de la situation actuelle une femme
conductrice de bus ou peintre en
bâtiment un homme sage-femme nous avons
rencontré des hiblinois qui dépassent
les clivages de genre un dossier réalisé
avec Michael Jay et Étienne Dang
Christine est chauffeur de bus depuis
2009 elle fait partie des CIN femmes de
la société ourtou à tenir le volant pour
un effectif de 150 personnes selon la
direction de l'entreprise ce n'est pas
par discr intion mais tout simplement
par manque de candidature mais ça
augmente depuis que je suis arrivé ça
augmenté quand même un petit peu parce
que quand je suis arrivée on était que
deux on arrive à être 5 mais bon en
France selon le comité interministériel
à l'égalité hommes-femm l'emploi féminin
se concentre aujourd'hui dans une
douzaine de familles professionnelles
sur un total de 87 clairement le
transport n'en fait pas partie 2014 doit
être l'année de la mixité des métiers le
gouvernement s'est fixé un objet
objectif d'ici 2025 un tiers des métiers
seront mixtes contre seulement 12 %
aujourd'hui pour Christine l'évolution
des mentalités est déjà en marche ça se
ressent un petit peu au début au niveau
clientèle mais ça se passe bien au bout
d'un petit moment vous connait et puis
ça passe tout seul peut-être que ça gêne
un petit peu certains hommes au début
mais on s'y fait et puis eux s'y font
les femmes en tout cas apprécient cette
diversité les femmes sont plus gentilles
c'est plus agréable puis il y a pas de
sexiste Christine a toujours aimé le
monde automobile après une certaine
lassitude dans son métier premier la
restauration c'est donc logiquement
qu'elle s'est tourné vers ce secteur
j'ai fait mon permis moto aussi donc
voyez je suis un petit
peu sport mécanique j'aime bien tout ce
qui est homme côté homme petit garçon
manqué peutêtre mais bon j'éta en même
temps milieu de garçon ça se comprend
peut-être les représentations ont la
denture même auprès des principaux
intéressés du côté de ses confrères
masculins en tout cas Christine a tout
de suite été accepté pas de
discrimination qu'en est-il des secteurs
désertés par les hommes il ne peut
sortir par le col de l'utérus que s'il
se dilate jusqu'à 10 cm Julien et
sagfemme diplômé en 1997 il était alors
le seul représentant masculin dans sa
promotion un secteur très féminin donc
mais un métier qu' a pleinement choisi
les gens étaient amusés alors mes
collègues étaient amusé parce qu'elles
en avaient pas beaucoup vu à l'époque
vraiment on était je crois que j'ai j'ai
peut-être dû être le 30e diplômé de
France un truc comme ça donc elles
étaient amusées c'était plutôt un bel
accueil les patientes je les ai
accueilliis dans un contexte d'urgence
au départ je faisais que de la salle de
naissance donc peu importe qui la reçoit
voilà et au final j'ai un accueil qui
est extrêmement chaleureux alors je sais
pas si c'est parce que je suis un homme
j'en sais rien mais c'est absolument pas
un boulet pour moi bien au contraire un
de ses atouts notamment on se souvient
de lui parce que c'est c'est un homme et
aussi parce que Julien est un personnage
qui met tout de suite à l'aise il
travaille aujourd'hui à son compte et
s'occupe de grossesse difficile à
domicile ce soir il intervient à la
maternité mot du chaîné il prépare de
futurs parents à l'accouchement avec
humour non ça vous fait peur non cool
bon ça si vous avez peur de ça laisse
tomber ce qui vous
arrive pour Julien la féminisation de sa
profession serait surtout du à son
intitulée tout le monde pense que c'est
une femme qui est sage la SAEM alors pas
du tout c'est quelqu'un qui détient le
savoir sur la femme donc on peut être un
homme et détenir le savoir sur la femme
ou être une femme et détenir le savoir
sur la femme euh on fait pas le même
métier que les gynécos obstétriciens
mais on en est pas très loin dès lors
qu'il s'agit d'obstétricien et ça choque
personne que ce soit un obstétricien
homme alors que ça peut entre guillemets
surprendre quand c'est une sache femme
de par le simple le nom ces patients
sont en tout cas ravis aucune
appréhension et pour cette future maman
la mixité est un point fort pour tous
les corps de métier on a des discours
différents des points de vue les femmes
n'ont pas la même façon d'imprender que
les hommes c'est pas le c'est pas la
même approche et et c'est bien que
d'avoir différents points de vue quoi
Julien ne dira pas le contraire filière
féminine ou masculine la non mixité
n'est jamais bonne maintenant je pense
que les femmes dans un milieu d'homme
doivent rencontrer d'autres types de
difficultés mais que ça doit pas être ni
plus facile ni moins facile que moi non
je pense que là où il y a pas de mixité
c'est compliqué voilà et c'est mon choix
d'exercer seul à la maison et en partie
dicté par le fait de quitter un peu
l'univers exclusivement féminin de la
salle de naissance parce que je
travaille qu'avec des femmes et je
soigne que des femmes et il y a un
moment donné où ça peut s'avérer un
petit peu pesant enfin voilà avec
beaucoup
d'amitié alors est-ce que la mixité
n'est qu'une question de temps
d'adaptation de la société d'éducation
pour le savoir nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de la jeune génération dans ce
centre de formation spécialisé dans le
BTP très peu de filles à la sortie des
cours les rares étudiants suivent la
formation en peinture considéré comme
moins physique elles y représentent 10 à
15 % des effectifs Chloé Madison sont en
première année de CAP les deux seules
filles de la classe elles ont choisi de
faire le métier qu'elles aiment sans se
soucier des préjugés j'ai pas forcément
fait attention que c'était pour les
hommes quoi donc c'est pas vraiment un
fr après c'est sûr au début de l'année
on a un pré parce qu'on est avec des
garçons mais après ça va faut prendre sa
place quoi en fait déjà nous on est
l'avantage c'est qu'on est deux filles
donc forcément on s'est rapproché l'une
de l'autre et après c'est sûr bah faut
savoir s'imposé en fait puis enfin au
fil des du temps B on est avec eux puis
on fait tout avec eux pu c'est limite on
est considéré comme un garçon en fait
quelque fois on nous charit un peu ça
c'est sûr mais sinon non il y a pas de
différence ça va on fait tout comme eux
quoi Chloé a 17 ans elle a connu ce
métier par son grand-père lui-même
peintre en bâtiment Madison 16 ans s'est
familiarisé avec avec ce secteur en
section secpa au collège leurs
formateurs regrettent ce manque de
visibilité de la filière le BTP est peu
mise en valeur dans les choix
d'orientation proposé aux jeunes et
surtout aux jeunes femmes en BTS oui sur
les niveaux supérieurs on en voit
quelques-unes mais en maçonnerie pure
étanchéité ou canalisation enfin non on
en voit pas encore c'est encore un monde
essentiellement
d'homme et je pense que c'est aussi
enfin par rapport à la dureté c'est pas
un métier qui est vendu déjà beaucoup
euh au collégien donc pour choisir ce
cette voie professionnelle là faut déjà
avoir soit des connaissances soit avoir
eu le métier présenté pour combler ce
manque Sébastien griffau compte mettre
ses recrues féminines en avant lors des
prochains forum d'orientation car selon
lui être une femme dans le BTP est un
atout ça devient de plus en plus courant
et ça s'est bien démocratisé au niveau
des entreprise qui apprécie en plus je
dirais le travail des filles le fait
qu'ell soit posée plus mature que qu'un
jeune garçon et très consciencieux dans
le travail en cas général en cas général
je précise un cliché de plus pour
Sébastien il s'agit plutôt d'une autre
vision du métier un enrichissement pour
la profession mais il faudra encore un
peu de temps avant qu'une femme se fonde
dans le décor Madison par exemple a subi
quelques remarques lors de ses stages
qu'est-ce que tu fais ici pourquoi tu
veux faire ça enfin la plupart il
comprennent pas pourquoi en fait les
jeunes l'acceptent mieux dans la filière
les fines ont en tout cas aucun problème
d'intégration avec leurs camarades un
bon espoir pour les futures
générations et c'est la fin de ce fil
pardon excusez-moi ce n'est pas la fin
de ce fil écho on passe d'abord à
l'agenda hop excusez-moi je retrouve mes
fiches elles sont ici un atelier pour
apprendre à soigner sa réputation
autrement dit à gérer son image sur la
toile et à mieux utiliser les réseaux
sociaux cette journée d'information se
tiendra le 28 janvier à la Cité des
Métiers à trappe de 10h30 à 12h30
attention il faut s'inscrire et une
deuxème date à retenir mercredi 29
janvier une permanence sera organisée
pour mieux comprendre les plans de
formation contrat de
professionnalisation contrat de
génération emploi d'avenir le numéro
pour vous inscrire s'affiche sur votre
écran les chefs d'entreprise sont donc
appelés à participer à cette séance de
9h30 à 1230 toujours au même endroit à
la Cité des Métiers cette fois-ci c'est
la fin de ce fil écho je vous donne
rendez-vous la semaine prochaine d'ici
là très bonne
semaine
[Musique]